Flammkuchen ist schnell zubereitet und
besonders günstig in der Herstellung
trotzdem sind Kunden bereit ordentliche
Summen für den beliebten Fladen
hinzublättern was würdet ihr dafür
bezahlen
Sebastian geht rein an den Speck und
zeigt wie sich die Industrie mit
billigen Belag eine goldene Nase trägst
[Musik]
was für ein schönes Restaurant die
passende Ablenkung für die Gerichte die
jetzt kommen
[Musik]
zur Eröffnung hat er sich Festgäste
eingeladen
ja herzlich willkommen in meinem
Restaurant mit einem Experiment mit
seinen Gästen will Sebastian zeigen wie
viel Geld sich in der Gastronomie mit
Convenience Produkten machen lässt
Beispiel Flammkuchen Flammkuchen ist die
französische Antwort auf Pizza nur eine
Pizza braucht hilfe muss intensiv
geknetet werden und braucht richtig Zeit
damit sie perfekt wird Flammkuchen
zwei drei vier fertig
flammkuchenteig wird nur angerührt und
kann direkt gebacken werden die Arbeit
übernimmt die Küchenmaschine sie
verknetet Mehl Salz Wasser und Öl
Zutaten für rund 20 Cent pro
flammkuchenteig
[Musik]
kein Triebmittel drin nichts weil es
soll ja hauchdünn und knusprig sein
Wahnsinn auf die Idee hätte auch mal
kommen sollen kaum ein Restaurant will
den Teig noch selber machen die
Lebensmittelindustrie nutzt das aus und
bietet für ein Euro fertigböden im 300er
Pack an ein gutes Geschäft auch für die
Restaurants denn sie sparen sich die
komplette Arbeit fertig vorbereitet gibt
es auch die Zutaten klassisch wird zum
Flammkuchen mit Creme fraiche bestrichen
das wird ein bisschen abgeschmeckt mit
Salz Pfeffer wie man mag und von Region
zu Region auch ein bisschen anders Creme
fresh entsteht durch stundenlange
Fermentation Nachteil die leicht
säuerliche Creme ist teuer selbst im
Großhandel kostet sie 7 € pro Kilo
darum hat die Lebensmittelindustrie eine
günstige Alternative entwickelt
[Musik]
und die wird so ähnlich wie ein Creme
frisch geschmacklich nachempfunden
die Basis der industriecreme besteht aus
Frischkäse der wird mit möglichst
billigen Pflanzenöl und etwas Sahne
gestreckt dazu kommen Gewürze wie Muskat
und Salz
und damit die Creme genau da bleibt wo
wir sie aufgestrichen haben ein bisschen
modifizierte Stärke
[Musik]
sogenannte flammkuchencreme die wird
schon für 4,88 € pro Kilo verkauft ein
Drittel weniger als Originale Creme
fresh
fehlt nur noch der Belag
den können Restaurants sind praktischen
großen Beuteln kaufen
kostet den Würfeln 43 Cent Proportion
auch Zwiebeln gibt es schon
vorgeschnitten für etwa einen Cent
Proportion die Böden und die Creme ist
ja fertig was drauf kommt ist völlig
egal hauptsache man kann schreiben
Flammkuchen und wenn das auf diesem
Brettern serviert wird ist es ja immer
schön groß die Leute und das Ganze für 9
€ günstig zum Belegen muss man keinen
ausgebildeter Koch sein der Flammkuchen
bleibt für weniger als eine Minute im
Ofen wenig Zeit viel Umsatz die
Personalkosten sind die höchsten und die
spielen dann natürlich mit rein also
wenn ich convenience Produkte verwende
brauche ich weniger Personal oder habe
geringere Personalkosten und dann ist
die Kalkulation am Ende dann trotzdem so
dass ich mehr verdiene
[Gelächter]
wenn das jetzt nicht gut aussieht ich
bitte Sie ja
schön groß
saftig
seinen Gästen serviert Sebastian heute
Flammkuchen nach Art der
Lebensmittelindustrie hausgemacht aus
vorgefertigten Zutaten
[Musik]
fertige Böden günstige flammkuchencreme
Speckwürfel und
vorgeschnittene Zwiebeln die Zutaten hat
Sebastian lege alle aus dem Großhandel
in 45 Sekunden ist ein Flammkuchen
bestrichen und belegt und dann ab in den
Ofen ruckzuck ist das Essen fertig
denken bestimmt das sind 20 Köche die
machen jeden Morgen den Teig frisch
pustekuchen
[Musik]
fast überall mit teuren Lebensmitteln
steigenden Mieten und hohen
Personalkosten
Sebastian lege hat Flammkuchen für seine
Gäste ganz alleine zubereitet ein
lukratives Modell für Restaurants
[Musik]
was würdet ihr dafür bezahlen 13,14 Euro
Flammkuchen den ist man jetzt nicht so
oft ja ich würde dafür 13 14 Euro zahlen
7 8 Euro mehr durfte nicht kosten 8 9
Euro
mit 10 € hätte Sebastian ordentlich
Gewinn gemacht
die Bretter sind leer es hat allen
gemundet und hier war mir wichtig was
ihr denkt was so ein Flammkuchen kostet
hier sind unsere Einkaufspreise pro
Flammkuchen und in den jeweiligen
Bestandteilen
rund 2€ hat Sebastian lege für die
Fertigprodukte ausgegeben unsere Gäste
hätten zehn gezahlt genau wie in den
meisten Restaurants eine traumhafte
Marge von fast
500%. auch deshalb ist der Flammkuchen
der aktuelle Liebling der Gastronomie
Flammkuchen dauert ein paar Sekunden
zack ist gebacken schmieren belegen rein
raus schmieren belegen rein raus jeder
der sich schon mal ein Brot geschmiert
hat der kann noch ein Flammkuchen backen
und deswegen ist das so lukrativ
im Belag steckt das eigentliche Geschäft
mit etwas Fantasie lässt sich die Marge
beim Flammkuchen spielen leicht weiter
steigern
Birnen wie unilever Food Solutions und
auf Flammkuchen spezialisierte Webseiten
unterstützen die Restaurants mit
Rezeptideen und den passenden Zutaten im
Angebot das Ziel Premium Flammkuchen zum
Premium Preis der Belag Trick bringt
renomme und Umsatz
[Musik]
Asia Style mit Radicchio Kürbis Dinkel
Spargel Flammkuchen Hawaii Flammkuchen
verfeinerungscreme
Rosenkohl Flammkuchen Flammkuchen
Zucchini Flammkuchen
[Gelächter]
bisschen Creme drauf
und der Rest ist Interpretation
der Trick für jede zusätzliche Zutat
sind Kunden bereit zusätzlich zu zahlen
und ungewöhnliche Beläge kosten extra
Beispiel Lachs Flammkuchen den Fisch
gibt es schon gewürfelt und tiefgekühlt
in der Großpackung
Speck für 43 Cent Proportion runter
und Lachs für 80 Cent drauf
[Musik]
bitte der klassische Elsässer noch 10
Euro verlangen Restaurants 13 bis 14 €
für die lachsvariante rund 40 Cent mehr
Zutaten bringen in diesem Beispiel 4 €
mehr Umsatz ohne mehr Arbeit für
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher ist es
super schwer anhand von Speisekarten zu
erkennen habe ich da jetzt wirklich ein
frisch gekochtes Essen das was ich in
einem Restaurant erwarte oder wird das
Ganze nur aus Fertigprodukten
zusammengesetzt eigentlich ist das gar
nicht möglich im Gegensatz zum
Supermarkt wo wirklich jedes Produkt
klar gekennzeichnet sein muss habe ich
auf der Speisekarte wirklich viel
weniger Möglichkeiten rauszufinden was
steckt wirklich in meinem Essen